να να ξέρει ξεκαταλάβει στον άθρωπον που λέ την αλήθεια που το ψεύτι εγώ τουλάχιστο
έχω των το χάρισμα λοιπόν τ το πράμα μίλησαμε κάμπως ος έσμε κόσμον να ννα
στέλλου μου και σιβή στειλά μου ανθρώποι πολλά δυνατού περιεχομένο επιστήμωνες αυτά και τα λοιπά
αν τα καταφέρω και υρώτους εγώ ίδεος δεν θα κατεύω εγώ όμως κρασήμερα ν κοινώες
μασοε να κάμεις κάτγαέγαμε γαμα και συνέντευσικε στον πορείτε πρέπ κι φτωμάδες πακει και καικαι
τπα και τι σκεφτουμε ότι πρέπει να γίνεις ξετούν τη χώρα για να α πωστο
στο δρόμο κάτο νομαναποφαίσε τωένα συνεχίσουν ταμετακαλοπου να το ύρουμε το ένας μάντης σε μου
πήγει να βάλουμε το όνόμα φως έρειγατί που πέρσε του λιγέντα αυτά λοιπόν ναξτιμε τ
κάπου κιμέπαι η κατασταση δας πούμε να καταλάει ε φελίκωσι τουμινός έχο μια πρόσκλαιση στην
ενδία στο γάμων ενός δισ κατομυρούχ πρόεσυν εργάτημου ο οποίος είναι καπνοκαπνοπαραγωγώσο ίδιοίχανος κάπνο παραγός
ι ιγή που έχιο και εφιτεύκει γανά μπορέρά πιο φορεσαν την κύπρο ανθρώπος τούτος είχε
μου βήφθυμε παγια ότιίχουν παρη καρπασί αλλά λέίμου στην κύπρο και υπάφος μαμασφέρει σε μας
κάτω και δόσιως βαστιγή πόσεξετωρα και μιλούμε τώρα εν πορακατες πόσι χαλιτικίνεγή κι οπάφος που
κάθεται μπορούμε να σας δείξουμε τον ό και να ξεκινήσετε ξανάσα χώρα να εξάγεται πνα
τα οποία εκάμε στα φεύκουν όπως τις φέραντα γαπράαν υπάρχουν που θενά και να γίνει
μια εταιρεα καπνών την οποία να ποιο κράτος να την πουλήσει να την κρατήσει ήθε
νας κάνει το άλλον κεφάλιοτούτι εταιρεία να έρτει να ποχροφήσει που της δημόσειαν υπηρεσία που
δυστυχώς γιαμέναν έντο μεγαλίτενο προλά της κύπρου αλλά ενκαον προσκοψις ομόνος τρόπος είναι να τους
βρίς καλύκτερες δουκίας πορά γίνουν πολλά πράγματα τα οποία να πω συμφορήσουν δανα γίνουν πιο
να γίνουν πιο κερδοφόρες επιχειρίς